Miri Polachek, thank you
for joining me on this show.
Glad to be here. Thanks for having me.
It's so so great to have you
Going to Boston University,
then to NYU Stern.
Moving on to all these great companies,
Teva, Pfizer, as financial analyst.
But then going on to Brain Technology,
and now finding yourself at Joy ventures.
And it must be the best name
that I can think of,
for any group or any organization.
I would love to be a part of a group
called the Joy Ventures one day.
So, you already have my resume on the way.
Awesome.
Miri, give me a little background
about what you're doing,
because it just sounds fascinating.
And take me through your journey
a little bit.
Sure. So, today what I'm doing
is running a really cool, as you said,
not only by name,
but really cool overall organization,
a very unique one, called Joy Ventures.
So, what we do, is we focus
on the wellness space.
Consumer products for well-being.
And we do so with a very unique model,
which is to build support
and fund companies.
So, we don't only invest
in existing startups, but we also work
with innovators and entrepreneurs
to actually build startups from scratch.
And we even go as deep as academia
to actually identify the promising
research and technology development.
To work with those folks as well to try
to turn those ideas and technologies
into products and companies.
Wait wait wait. Hold on.
I need you to walk me
through that process of,
because I get this idea of investing
in existing companies.
Young entrepreneurs come up to you
and they say,
"We have this great idea."
"We need some support
so that we can grow and scale
and validate our product."
But you're saying
you have a different model.
It rings a bell to some of what
my friends and teammates are doing.
Exactly. So, it's very similar.
Yeah. So, there are some parallels
to teammate.
So basically, this is a model that
is actually becoming quite common
in terms of the startup building.
So, it has many names today in the market.
Startup studio, venture builder.
Yeah, those are probably
the most popular terms for what we do.
And basically, what it means is sometimes,
even if you don't even have an idea yet
or, you're really just excited
about the space,
perhaps you're an experienced entrepreneur
and you're looking
for your next challenge,
you can come to us,
or to this kind of organization.
Specifically, if you're interested
in our domain, you come to Joy, of course.
And actually, we've just launched
this week our new entrepreneur
in residence program.
EIRs are coming common in various VCs.
Here, what we're doing is basically,
working with a couple of EIRs
who just joined this week.
They're experienced founders.
They've had exits.
They've got the methodology down.
But now they're going to deep dive
into our space
and try to either work with our ideas
that we've actually, we've built this idea
back through various innovation programs
that we've run with our community.
So, they can either take some of the ideas
off of our shelves,
or, they can just deep dive
into market research.
Be inspired by their understanding
of the market needs,
and then come up with their own idea.
And then, actually spend
six to eight months developing that idea
into a mockup prototype.
Putting together a business plan,
all with our support as needed.
And then, come to us
at the end of their EIR program period.
And basically pitch their idea to us
so that hopefully,
by the end of that period,
we would be ready to invest
and start a company with them.
Wow. Okay. So, that sounds incredible.
So, it sounds like you're really tackling
the part of the validation of the product
and the validation of the market
through your experience.
And I mean, having people
that have gone through the journey
and have done this validation,
and this research, I think it's priceless.
But then, the real struggle
is then finding the people who are willing
to take on this incredible journey
for seven to nine years, right?
And marry and be passionate
about the product,
and marry the company.
So, do you find that
to be at a similar caliber
to the research?
How do you go about even evaluating people
who are coming in really fresh,
or you're looking to match people
to a certain idea from this idea being?
Yeah, it's definitely not easy.
It took us actually,
I think, close to six months
recruiting this first cohort of EIRs.
We are really looking
for a mix of the right experience,
obviously a cultural fit.
Because they're going to be
really part of the Joy team
for the next six to eight months.
So, we really wanted to make sure
that there was good chemistry.
And that we felt that there was also
some basic connection to our domain.
We want people to really be passionate
about consumer products,
to be passionate about
human centered design.
And ultimately, when we build companies,
or support companies,
we want to have actually
a really strong multidisciplinary team
that obviously has to have
a really strong entrepreneur
and founder at the helm.
But you also obviously want to have
strong tech and strong product.
Especially, since we're
in the consumer product space.
We really want people
to have a good understanding
of market consumer trends and so on.
So, one of the things
that you mentioned right before this,
was also this idea of wellness products
and products that ultimately
bring good to the world
and promote wellness, promote well-being.
What does that mean to you?
Give me some tangible examples.
What does that mean
thinking about products
that are for well-being or for good?
Yeah. So, it's funny.
And this is maybe, a good place
to talk about my journey.
Because, I was born in Israel.
I grew up in Boston.
My parents relocated to Boston for work.
My dad was in high tech.
My mom is a neuroscientist.
And actually, that's where my first,
my first exposure was, to the brain.
And it's a fascinating organ
that controls our lives.
And so, from a very young age,
this was part of the kitchen talk
and it was always very inspiring.
And I had a really great role models.
And even to this day,
when I'm almost 50 years old,
I still talk about
what great models my parents are
very often in my interviews.
And so, when I went on to study,
even though I didn't go into life sciences
or technology, in my education,
I chose economics and business.
What I found myself, though,
really connecting to
was the life science industry.
And so, very quickly, I found myself
going into the pharmaceutical industry.
And there, I was exposed to many of the
central nervous system illnesses.
Both Teva and Pfizer, are companies
that are very strong in neuroscience.
For developing products for things like
Alzheimer's, Parkinson's, depression, etc.
And I think, Miri,
what you're saying here
is you went into these companies
as a financial analyst, right?
You took your economics degree
and you brought that into those companies.
Yet, what you're describing here,
you're not describing
your analytical work,
you're describing the passion
that you've accumulated over the years
for the life sciences.
What I found about myself very quickly
was that, there are two things
that really drive me to an organization,
into a position.
One, is the subject matter.
So, it doesn't matter
if I'm crunching numbers,
or if I'm doing any kind of marketing,
or management, or any kind of role.
I really need to connect
with the organization's mission.
And the second thing is, obviously,
the people, as you know, as cliches,
that is connecting with the people
that I'm going to be working with.
And what made me stay at any organization
for such a long time
was really just because
I've worked with really smart, inspiring
good people, high integrity people.
And so, what I found myself doing
was really working
in the pharmaceutical industry
learning about not only,
how to be a good financial manager,
but also about brain illness
and about how a drug
basically is developed and goes to market.
And how it's actually then
marketed and promoted
over the products' long lifecycle
in the case of innovative pharmaceuticals.
And I also experienced a short time
in the non-pharma health care industry.
I worked for a physician practice
management organization.
Also a very large publicly traded company,
a SVP finance.
But then, when we moved back to Israel
actually 10 years ago,
after living in New York for 12 years
with my husband,
three kids were born here,
I found that I really still
was very passionate
about the lifescience industry.
But that I wanted to really make a shift
from big corporate
to sensing the more early stage
startup nation environment.
Which is such a really amazing
and unique environment
here in Tel Aviv, here in Israel.
Very different from the positions
that you've held up until now.
Very very different.
Just a different company, Pfizer, Teva.
Yeah, extremely different.
And as a matter of fact,
when I first came back,
when I was networking
and no one knew me here really
because I hadn't grown up here.
I didn't go to the army here.
I didn't start my career here.
I spent 12 years in New York.
Even though I had
very admirable positions,
in Israel, obviously,
people want to see your back.
People want to know you.
And they want also to see
a relevant track record.
So, when I went started talking to VCs
in startups about joining, they said,
"Well, you've never done this before."
So, it doesn't matter that you have
15, 20 years experience.
You've never raised money.
You've never commercialized,
or brought a product to market.
So, that was rough.
But really, what happened,
and this is the word that I always use,
is serendipity.
It's one of my favorite words in English,
which I don't think we have in Hebrew.
It was just luck and timing.
And I had learned.
I just found out about,
I read in the media, actually,
about our former president, Shimon Peres,
announcing that he's going to launch
this initiative to drive
brain research and technology in Israel.
To turn Israel
into a leading technology hub.
And that vision really resonated with me.
Because obviously, neuroscience
was such a big passion
for me all those years.
As well as, the whole concept
and the whole vision was really about
innovation and about startups, and about
bringing the brain tech startup ecosystem
to the next level.
Or even creating an ecosystem
which really didn't exist.
I mean, the different parts
of the small Israeli community
of brain researchers, entrepreneurs,
clinicians, whether it's the neurologists,
psychiatrists, neurosurgeons,
no one was really talking to each other.
And there weren't really
investors in Israel looking at the space.
So, or at least, they were
only looking at it very initially.
And what IBT, Israel Brain Technologies,
which we ended up establishing
with Rafi Gidron, a very famous
serial entrepreneur in Israel,
and which I led for almost seven years.
What we ended up doing was actually
bringing that ecosystem together.
Breaking down all those silos
and creating programs for that community,
including a startup accelerator
for Brain Tech companies
and International Brain Tech Conference,
funding for brain researchers, etc,
to really push that sector forward
and really establish Israel as a strong
international brain technology hub.
And we really brought
lots of important stake,
global stakeholders to Israel
for that conversation.
And so, that was
a really amazing journey for me,
because it really, in a way,
it forced me to leave
the big corporate greenhouse.
It was an entrepreneurial venture,
even though it was a not for profit.
But it was really my first startup.
And it allowed me to keep my passion
in life science, in neuroscience,
in innovation.
But also, brought out in me
the more broader leadership which before,
was limited to my financial hat.
Now, I was able to really be
the evangelist for this organization.
To be the person
that brings people together.
And to really lead
all the strategic aspects
and put together this whole operation,
which I'm really proud of.
It's really, to this day,
I think it's one of the most
really special experiences that
I've had professionally in my career.
So, and that brings me at the end to Joy.
Wait, Miri, I have so many questions now.
I don't even know where to roll on.
We're going to have to have
an extra long episode this time.
I have to know,
so, first of all, brain technology.
It's a black box to so many people
like myself, that it feels like,
it's such a complicated field
that I have to go and study
biology and neuroscience,
and if I even want to begin
to understand what's happening.
So, dumbed down for me a little bit.
What can I be excited
about brain technology today?
And if we're extrapolating
a little bit further ahead,
five, 10 years in the future,
what are some of the most
exciting advances in your mind
as to brain technology?
And perhaps, how it literally
can shape our lives?
I'm constantly inspired by Nathan Intrator
from Tel Aviv University with Neurosteer.
That's about the scope of I know
and the work he does.
I think, it's a good place to start.
Still, I don't undertand anything
from what he does.
So, I need you to dumb it down for me.
Talk to me a little bit about it.
So, I think brain technology
can be defined and interpreted
in a variety of ways.
So, some people think of brain technology
as only the type of technology
that directly interacts with your brain.
Like brain computer interface.
Any type of technologies
that either measure your brain waves
or your brain activity in some way,
or actually influence your brain activity.
Right?
Like brain stimulation,
whether it's deep brain
invasive stimulation
or non-invasive brain stimulation.
So, that's just one piece.
But the way I like to think
of brain technology,
is really any kind of technology,
any kind of innovation
that can really measure
or affect our brain state,
or our brain health.
So, if you think technology more broadly,
I mean, in a way,
it can also be pharmaceuticals
that can treat brain illness.
But it can also be some kind of app,
that can somehow,
through the various sensors
that we have in our phones or wearables,
we can somehow monitor our stress level,
or, monitor our anxiety level,
our mood depression levels.
So, there are startups out there
that are now tracking
behavioral or mental wellbeing.
Companies that have raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
like Mindstrong and others
that are helping people
who are living with mental illness
better manage their illness.
Helping their caregivers and loved ones
be a part of that caregiving
and make sure that they get
just in time alerts,
if there is something wrong going on.
So, it doesn't always
necessarily have to be a cure.
Doesn't have to be
the ultimate solution for Parkinson's.
But if we're doing anything
to improve people's well-being or health,
and that kind of brings me
to the joy part of brain tech.
Which I mean, we don't only do
brain tech at Joy,
but we're looking at it.
Most of the years, I was involved
in companies or organizations
that were focused very much
on brain illness and trying to find ways
to help people who have various types
of brain disorders.
What we really focus on at Joy
is the other side, which is,
the majority of people around the world.
luckily, although these days during covid,
and I'll talk about that in a minute.
It's a different story, but maybe,
only one in four are suffering from,
it's still a huge number,
from mental illness.
And there are other statistics
related, obviously,
to neurodegenerative disorders.
But the majority of people
at any given moment
are just are generally healthy
from a brain perspective, let's say,
or from a well-being perspective.
They may have other issues.
We have a lot of big issues in the world
regarding chronic disease, and heart,
and obesity and so on.
But most people are just dealing
with modern life.
And that means stress.
And that means poor sleep.
And that means anxiety.
And sometimes, just feeling down.
And all those things are not,
they're not diagnosed conditions.
They're not described as some illness
that you necessarily
have to go to get a prescription for
to start some medical treatment.
But we're learning more and more
about ourselves.
That they really affect
our quality of life.
So, if it's for the last 20 years,
people have been really focused
on understanding that
they need to take care of their bodies
through nutrition and exercise,
people are becoming more aware
in recent years that,
Okay, I also have to take care
of this part of my body.
I need to make sure that I'm relaxed.
That I'm finding ways to reduce stress
and find ways
to just improve my daily life.
Because the stress isn't going anywhere.
In most cases, I mean,
some people have a choice,
but a lot of people are going to be
in high stress jobs.
They're going to have
not only stress at home, I mean at work,
they're going to have stress at home.
The young generation is balancing,
I mean, the highest level of stress today
is experienced by the young generations
who are balancing work and life.
And they're working very intensively.
But the good news is that young generation
is actually much more aware.
They are embracing technology.
They're already the ones
that are trying meditation and yoga
and all those things.
But they're trying to see
if they can find the solutions
through their phones,
or through any gadgets or devices.
Because they're very tech savvy
and digitally native.
Now that you mention this
and it's funny because I,
so, I do enjoy taking part
in a lot of projects
and various opportunities.
And oftentimes,
that goes instead of sleep.
And my girlfriend was very angry with me
because she's rightfully saying that,
sleep is one of the most important things.
And I'm not even aware
of how it's affecting my mind or my body.
So, I got this ring with inspiration.
Is that oura?
Yeah, it's an oura ring.
Yeah. Oura's awesome.
We love oura.
I've been wearing it for about two weeks.
We had one in the office,
but someone lost it.
So, now we have to order a new one.
We're fighting over it.
Everyone was using it. Yeah.
Amazing. But now, I have to,
every morning I wake up,
I look at my phone and I realize that,
okay, it's not that I got
six hours of sleep,
but it's how much quality sleep
that I get.
And I resonate so much
with the things that you're saying
about brain technology.
And I had an interesting episode
with a friend, Dan Seidir from Palo Alto,
and he has bipolar disorder.
He wrote extensively about it
in various tech magazines.
And he's working on a startup
where he's trying to help people
combat bipolar disorder
by using the webcam of the computer
to observe their facial expressions
when they're working, not on Zoom
when we're all smiling and happy,
but in the mundane day to day life
to give feedback.
And one thing that I've realized
over the past few months here
is that there's just not enough people
that are working on these things.
Not on the illness side of it,
and not in the wellness side of it.
Which is why I think,
what you're doing at Joy venture
is really really awesome.
I totally agree.
I'm glad you've realize that.
Because I think that there's such a huge
ocean of opportunity to innovate
both for people
who have more serious suffering.
I also have a brother
who suffers from mental illness.
And that's another reason why
it's also close to my heart.
And that field of mental illness
desperately needs innovation.
And I think,
all of the artificial intelligence,
and brain inspired computing,
and all these great talent also
that's out there.
Part of my mission has been,
in the last 10 years,
whether at Israel Brain Technologies
or at Joy, is to try to get people
who come out with these fabulous degrees
from very prestigious institutes
to actually explore this new space.
Yeah. So, I really would love
more and more people
to discover this world of brain health,
brain tech innovation.
What does it take for more entrepreneurs
to get excited about it?
Because I feel, and coming in now
from both 8200 and Stanford,
I'm getting a sense of understand
why it's difficult
for a lot of people to start.
And I think it stems from this perception
that while I may be excited
about engineering and data science,
going into the field of neuroscience,
I feel like I need to get a PhD in this
in order to just begin
to understand what's happening.
If so, that's not the case.
It's really not the case.
I think, first of all,
find a neuroscientist
and partner with them.
I mean, there are plenty
of neuroscientists out there
that would love to use
their knowledge and discoveries
in a way that can help people.
So, I think it's about,
and it doesn't only take place
in academia.
I mean, there's a lot of great things
that can happen.
But I mentioned all these examples
of ways that, ultimately,
it's understanding
what are the pains out there
that people have and just seeing
how you can even bring even just
off the shelf technology in a way.
The reason why we think
that it's such a great opportunity today,
is because, not only is science
come so far, but technology's come so far
that you can do so much today
with available technology.
Just finding a way to make it accessible
to people who need it.
And there's so many great things
that you can do today
to influence our state of mind,
whether it's mixed reality,
using VR, AR.
And EEG is just one part of measuring.
But here's so many ways
that you can influence.
There's so many ways
to stimulate our brain, right?
We can stimulate our cell,
any of the senses, all of our senses,
and affecting how we feel.
Right?
So, it's enough that for you
to do some vibration on my wrist
and you can help me calm down.
It doesn't have to be this deep tech
brain stimulation.
It can be just, hey,
it can even be just a game.
So, we look at companies now
that are doing really cool games
to help kids deal with their emotions,
train kids from a very young age
to be more empathetic.
Teach them empathy.
Teach them kindness.
So, it's about not only feeling good,
but it's also, making us better people.
And I think, as long as,
you're the kind of person
that wants to also do something good,
and you're really passionate
about technology,
there's no reason why you can't mix
both of those up.
And it doesn't mean that doing good
doesn't make money.
There's huge markets
for all of these types of applications.
And it's only growing.
If you take, maybe my last comment
will just be that these days
with the global pandemic,
it's just unbelievable
the impact that it's had
on people's emotional well-being,
and general well-being.
I mean, I think, there are a lot of people
that until now didn't realize,
or didn't say,
"Oh, yeah, I'm also stressed."
They always see people around them and,
"Oh, it's not my problem."
But now, there isn't, I think
one person on the planet
that hasn't experienced the stress
and anxiety and depression
associated with this whole uncertainty
around the pandemic.
Whether it's financially driven
because someone is no longer working,
or just not knowing
what's going to happen tomorrow.
The social isolation
and all the loneliness
that it's causing people,
all of those things.
I mean, they're manifesting themselves
and just accelerating the awareness
and the need for solutions
to help people cope
with very high levels of stress,
lack of sleep, etc.
So, anything we can innovate
to bring people together
through the screens
to help people feel better,
to reduce their stress.
And it's not just meditation.
Meditation isn't for everyone.
There's a lot of noise around meditation,
through headspace and calm,
and it's great.
But not everybody likes it.
And it's not the only way
to help people feel good.
So, we're really putting
the call out there
for really smart, passionate
techs and entrepreneurs,
to think about how can technology
serve humanity's quest for well-being.
What kind of products
can we develop for consumers.
Of course, it's important to treat people
with brain illness, and,
but at the same time,
there's so much opportunity
to look at consumers.
The day to day,
if it's our grandmothers,
if it's our children,
if it's our brothers and sisters,
just help them find ways to feel good,
to connect with each other
and to create healthy habits.
Miri, before we leave, two notes.
One, if people have this passion
for wellness and for,
I love what you said,
going about solving the human quest
for wellness and wellbeing,
and not just about illnesses.
But I'm looking at my own grandparents
and how there is so little solutions
that connect the younger generation
to the older generation.
It's unbelievable that I'm watching,
as a part of J-Ventures, I get to watch
hundreds of different startups
come in yearly.
So few of them are dealing
with these issues that are so prevalent
and they were just growing.
I mean, the gap is just increasing
every day that goes by.
So, definitely, they should reach out
to Joy Ventures, I guess.
And I think that your're a perfect address
to give them advice,
and to talk them through their ideas
and where we're headed.
And the second thing,
the last thing that I always love to do
is I'm going to put you on the spot
one time during this interview.
And I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself,
or that anybody on your team would use
to describe yourself, or Rafi,
or any of the entrepreneurs
that you're helping.
So, if it's describing me,
I think "optimism"
is a really big part of who I am.
I really believe in the ability to,
I really see things
with the half full cup.
I think that your work at Joy Ventures,
you bring optimism to the table already,
just with a name.
Yeah. Yeah. But it really is who I am.
It's not just on paper.
And for me, also another big piece,
is "connecting".
So, I really love
bringing people together.
And I think that
with innovation and startups,
that's also really super important.
I think when we deal with innovation,
it's not just about one person.
It's really about,
not only going out and talking to people
and understanding
what are people's pains,
but also forming teams
and working together.
And that's a big passion of mine.
It's like enabling innovation
through connecting people
and connecting organizations and people
with different areas of expertise.
And I guess,
because of this conversation we've had,
I think we're going to need
to put the word "brain" as the third one.
Because brain or brain tech, I think,
is going to be another good key word.
So, yeah, let's go for those.
So, optimist, unity and brain. I love it.
I think it's a wonderful combination.
Miri, I can't wait to learn more
about what you guys do at Joy Ventures.
And it resonates so much
because the reason
I came here to Palo Alto after the union
was to understand
what are some of the biggest challenges
that technology can help solve.
And the more I'm exposed to these ideas,
the more passionate I get at them.
And definitely I can see myself
taking part in this world
that you're surrounded in.
And it just sounds fantastic.
Miri, thank you
for being so generous with your time.
Thank you for allowing me to run over
because I enjoyed this interview so much.
This is definitely longer than usual.
But I just loved every minute of it.
So thank you very much.
I enjoyed it too, Michael.
Thank you so much for inviting me.
It's been a real joy.
And good luck with this program.
It's a really wonderful initiative.
I hope you enjoy it to.
Thank you. Thank you very very much.
Take care.
All the best. Good health.